you find out a lot about your friends I
still didn't chin Istanbul you find a
lot about your friends during this time
of crisis yeah it's like you know I want
you my [ __ ] foxhole dude I might like
I'll tell you who after so I go dude go
to this and give me the address where
you got toilet paper he's like they're
not limited so I just bought a shitload
like you know but if other people need
that I didn't [ __ ] go what happens if
other people need it I was just talking
about he's like yeah I don't know it
sounds like they're probably oh I can't
we can't be friendly I agree i went to i
go to Gelson's and i go and it's all
empty i go these [ __ ] losers you
[ __ ] hoarding toilet paper and all
this stuff how about an election you
probably love you [ __ ] that's all like
help people you selfish little [ __ ] you
scared [ __ ] what a scared selfish [ __ ]
I have some other friends I was texting
with last night about specials they go
dude I think the comic store is gonna
shut down
I don't think torn be back to 2021 on it
oh wow you will dude I'm glad this
happened defeat we're not the same yeah
I'm out dude good for real a real
[ __ ] if the zombie apocalypse come
you better you're the first one dying
guys and I don't want to [ __ ] you
definitely not my team and we're not
because you're gonna run out who's on
your team people are freaking the [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] dude don't leer on kronas bad it
in our lifetime maybe now you're in our
lifetime yeah
there's you mean way worse [ __ ] that
happens and if this is this is how
you're acting various all right Bubba
I agree but I'm glad I'm seeing their
colors it's a practice run bro State
this is they always say in so whenever
you write a script a movie you
highlights to who somebody truly is when
they're under pressure
yes and we know this you know who
somebody is when the chips are down when
the house is on fire you don't know
somebody is when everything's good can
you behave like a gentleman when you
don't feel like a gentleman can you
behave brave when you're terrified you
know or whatever it is that these are
really important things you really find
out how your friends are man finite but
sometimes a crisis like I remember this
is years ago strand by when my I think
it was a second home and I taught and it
was like down to the wire getting
approved and I dude you need this much
more money account like what there's a
big number like what the [ __ ] am I gonna
do so I thought you called me to check
on the house
like I mean it's happened man I have to
have it in by 4:00 p.m. I need this much
money go and I wasn't Brian wasn't call
me that for any reason just to check on
the house and this is about five six
years ago and I go ah they need like
this much more money you go well how
much money do you have my telling you go
just take out the account what you like
just take you out fine kid account like
I'll do I don't need to do that just
take it out don't just do it yeah yeah
that's right [ __ ] hits the force I did
that yeah and of course I know you stole
money for the best four years but that's
but that's not the point that Brian you
not the point is not during a time of
crisis Brian came through the point you
inside of though it is of course I did
yeah the point is I'm a man I'm not a
[ __ ] and I can't stand selfish people
and I that that's my biggest thing cuz
one yourself is what I don't see
yourself as what I see as a [ __ ] and a
coward me too that's what I see I'm like
Hoffa like [ __ ] happens you're oh you
guys you'll run the other way wait are
we friends I know friends means I'm
gonna help you hide a body
yeah friends means I go to I go extreme
they do because you do you and I were in
situation I never forgot and you got
nervous because there were a certain
biker there was a certain biker gang
that that was over in a corner and you
got a little nervous because sometimes
they'll challenge a guy like you another
one and I remember thinking to myself
and you know I I remember I think I said
here I go well I'll take it out I'm a
speed yeah yeah I mean I don't know what
I'm gonna be able to do but I'm
definitely gonna be knee to knee with
all I know we're though yeah yeah but I
mean but but I'm that's bad sign us up
it's a bad situation because you know
they recognize me as a guy yeah now you
can beat up a thousand people but that's
a different thing we're there but I as a
man please I'm not [ __ ] I ain't
running yeah
I'm right there wait it's gonna suck and
I'm gonna be afraid but I can't go
anywhere otherwise everything I've been
doing in my whole life is a lie I just
understood I've never understood people
that dip shits dip shits that that it's
always the guys that call you brother
brother like when the [ __ ] when
everything's good brother
come on brother bro bro you're my friend
are a my a my because you're not very
generous when it is strange we see their
true colors
generosity mm-hmm I'd rather be generous
it's not about being brave it really
isn't
it's about being generous and it's about
I mean that's that's what that's when
you know my father drilled that [ __ ]
into me I saw my father in my life when
the chips were really down I've seen
people like Jimmy Burke I've seen people
like my father when the chips are really
down when it really am but I've seen
them [ __ ] step up like men
yeah it shamed me it I went like they
step up it's good to see this and even
in situations where they're their own
they could have been really hurt yep and
I've always admired that it's what I
hope I can say that I don't know maybe
I'll run away I don't [ __ ] else yeah
yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue oh good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]